à bombay dans les centres de vaccination
les files d'attentes sont quasi
inexistantes
l'un des premiers producteurs de vaccins
au monde et sa capitale économique n'en
n'ont pourtant pas fini avec leurs
campagnes de vaccination
bien au contraire à ce jour selon le
site internet kobe tracker seul 98
millions de doses de vaccin anti
qu'ovide ont été administrées dans ce
pays d'un milliard trois cents millions
d'habitants et les doses manque suis
venu ici pour me faire vacciner mais ils
m'ont dit qu'ils n'avaient pas de stock
alors je suis rentré chez moi ils m'ont
demandé de revenir demain aujourd'hui
nous sommes allés au bureau de par l bmc
ils nous ont demandé de revenir dans
trois quatre jours pour récupérer le
stock de vaccins car il n'avait pas de
stock disponible aujourd'hui l'état du
maharashtra où se trouve bombay a même
pris la décision d'arrêter de vacciner
ce vendredi dans le poumon économique du
pays
dès jeudi les 72 établissements privés
chargés d'administrer les doses étaient
arrivés au bout de leurs stocks
cette situation catastrophique couple
est au plus de 120 mille nouveaux cas
enregistrés en 24 heures un record pour
le pays a poussé bombay son état se
confiner depuis ce samedi et durant tout
le mois d'avril
les magasins seront fermés chaque week
end et les 125 millions d'habitants
priés de rester chez eux
il devrait y avoir les deux le
confinement et la possibilité pour les
gens de gérer leurs affaires
il n'y a pas d'activité nous devrions au
moins être capable de gagner un peu
d'argent pour faire face à nos dépenses
on a des enfants et des familles on
devrait être au moins capables de les
nourrir
cette mise sous cloche la première
depuis le confinement nationale de mars
2020 risque d'accroître un peu plus les
fortes inégalités dans l'état le plus
riche d'inde en juin dernier
la banque mondiale avait estimé à 12
millions le nombre d'indiens tomber dans
une situation d'extrême pauvreté à cause
de ce confinement généraliser les
projections des nations unies envisager
que 104 millions d'autres indiens
passeraient sous le seuil de pauvreté
portant à 920 millions le nombre
d'habitants très vulnérable soit près de
70% de la population indienne la
situation indienne pourrait aussi avoir
des répercussions sur d'autres pays
moins développés qu'il y ait du
programme onusien kovacs depuis le début
de la crise l'inde a exporté 64 millions
de doses vers l'afrique l'asie du sud ou
encore le brésil désormais outre les
mesures restrictives le pays freinent
voir stop toute exportation de vaccins
vers l'étranger pour donner la priorité
à sa population